le soleil n'était pas encore au
rendez-vous cette semaine mais
qu'importe les vacances sont bien là à
montigny le bretonneux l'été en sable a
posé ses valises au gymnase alain colas
châteaux de sable toboggan et activités
en tous genres un programme qui fait le
bonheur des petits comme des plus grands
je suis avec mon petit fils il a une
grande soeur qui est partie en colonie
donc c'est la campagne sa soeur en
attendant qu'elle revienne
on est venu un vélo il fait ça repart à
vélo donc ça fait du sport pour lui et
pour moi aussi c'est la deuxième année
parce que ma petite fille ya quatre ans
cette année mais sinon avant quand mes
enfants étaient était petit ça
n'existait pas citer dommage parce que
c'est vraiment bien pour les pour les
enfants et tout est gratuit donc il n'ya
pas de problème
tous les enfants peuvent participer de
la même façon sans oublier le petit
train à retrouver comme l'an dernier et
est en sable est accessible tous les
jours jusqu'au 20 août
trappes plage revient aussi pour une
nouvelle édition à la piscine municipale
jacques moncaut structures gonflables
jeux de ballons ou glissade des
animations sont même proposés à la
piscine ce jour là alexandre maître
nageur a donné un cours d'aquagym
d'autres rendez vous sont prévus tout
l'été fin juillet on aura une
animation trappe lanta c'est un peu sur
le modèle de koh lanta donc céder des
activités aquatiques et des parcours
notamment dans l'eau dans la piscine qui
a reçu également tout au long de la
journée des parcours sur la plage des
baptêmes de plongée seront également
proposés par un club spécialisé
vous avez jusqu'au 13 août pour en
profiter et pour prolonger encore un peu
les vacances nos repas estival est à
retrouver boulevard du rein du 7 août au
1er septembre
avec une nouveauté cette année le site
accessible les week-ends et les jours
fériés